today we are tackling insurance as we
continue our pet week lots of buzz on
how this works what's covered how to
select the right one for your pet
christian kosovo is breaking it down to
help you avoid any financial nightmares
what do they mean to you everything
everything without my dogs
uh i don't know what i would do
i met mary tully during her daily walk
around desert breeze park
by her side seven-year-old zaza and
four-year-old fifi
tully has health insurance for both her
babies it
seems to work out real well
so if they get sick or anything happens
to them you know
even if they pass away i you know it's
it's used
pet insurance has been around for more
than 100 years with policies on
livestock
and did you know that in 1982 tv's most
famous dog
lassie was the first in the u.s to have
a pet insurance policy
today 3.1 million pets were insured at
the end of 2020.
the best thing to do is get insurance on
your itty-bitty baby puppy or kitten
because then they're covered for all the
silly kitten and puppy stuff they do
like eating socks and rocks and all of
those things
and then they're covered for their their
old dog stuff down the road too
jenna mahan represents embrace which
offers a variety of coverage
dental chronic and orthopedic there are
about 20 pet insurance companies
to determine the best one for you
research i'd be careful about
uh spending more money for
preventative or routine care
because that would that's almost like
ensuring the oil changes on your car
you know you wouldn't do that data from
a recent survey shows surgical vet
expenses and dogs are almost
double than those on cats as well as
most other costs
you have to give a pet owner an estimate
of fifteen thousand dollars for
the surgery that the dog needs to have
or it's
not gonna make it i don't have insurance
i can't afford insurance
i would love to have insurance and that
is what some pet owners think like
nicole newland the cost
depends on the coverage you get this
insurance company provides free quotes
a standard policy on a medium-sized
puppy would cost you about forty dollars
for a kitten the cost would drop to
about 20 bucks
i use it if they get sick or something
yeah i use that
christian casadas 8 news now
now pet insurance companies say vet
medicine has come a long way in the last
20 years you can get
ct scans mris like what humans get with
the increase in quality of medicine
comes an increase though in cost basic
advice is knowing what kind of policy
you want
do that necessary research and find what
best fits your dog's needs